good morning Hank it's Tuesday remember
back in May when I told you that your
birthday present would be a little late
well it's here I was thinking what do
you get a 38 year old man who has no
interest in worldly luxuries and then I
realized you get him a billboard so I
got you a billboard actually I got you
several billboards near our childhood
home in Orlando Florida like remember
our childhood 7-eleven where we used to
bike to get Slurpees boom billboard also
remember Wally's I got you a billboard
there too there are a few others around
town it turns out renting billboards is
a bit addictive if you live in Orlando
and want to check out these beauties and
personnel put some links in the
doobly-doo okay so there's more you may
recall a few months ago that I was like
I enjoy sponsoring AFC Wimbledon so much
and it has made me want to sponsor other
things right that was a trick I was
actually seeking to buy sponsorships for
an absolutely remarkable thing let's
start with AFC Wimbledon the world's
favorite third tier English football
team in addition to having some
excellent ads around the stadium an
absolutely remarkable thing has become
AFC Wimbledon's training kit sponsor
seen here in the run-up to their recent
game against West Ham United also you
sponsor the Firebirds first robotics
team out of flower town Pennsylvania as
well as the doc bot X ro bot XT min
Canada seen here with absolutely
remarkable thing and 10 I and the
beginnings of their robot who is named
Karl
you also sponsor FIRST robotics teams in
Fort Wayne Indiana and Carmel Indiana as
well as FRC rapid acceleration in Rapid
City South Dakota an absolutely
remarkable thing also sponsors are made
of Awesome Speech and Debate team in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma and one in West
Anchorage Alaska then there's castle the
2018 UC Berkeley solar car team which is
building testing and racing street-legal
solar powered vehicles an absolutely
remarkable thing sticker will be on
their next car called tachyon on the
sports front an absolutely remarkable
thing is the official Sox sponsor of the
Austin torch a professional women's
Ultimate Frisbee team in Austin Texas
also Hankey sponsored the Montana State
University Women's Rugby Club who were
nice enough to make these absolutely
remarkable thing rugby balls and you
sponsored the amazing Stockbridge high
school girls lacrosse team in Georgia
but wait you say what about baseball
well Hank what if I were to tell you
that next spring a group of young people
outside Boston will learn about hitting
and catching and teamwork that group of
young people the Mission Hill absolutely
workable things really here's some of
them our last season oh my god the
cuteness now I know what you're
wondering Hank where's the Quidditch
well don't worry you are now the left
sleeve sponsor of the Dutch national
Quidditch team the Flying Dutchman and
that sponsorship makes it possible for
them to compete in the 2019 Quidditch
European game speaking of Harry Potter I
also got you some sponsorships on a
podcast we both love Harry Potter and
the sacred texts but wait there's more
Hank your book is also sponsoring the
University of the Western Cape rowing
team in South Africa making it possible
for them to travel around the country
for competitions and an absolutely
remarkable thing sponsors a rugby team
composed of future doctors at the
University of Glasgow as well as a high
school quiz bowl team in Ohio now of
course thank your book does not need me
or those sponsorships to get people
excited about it it has received glowing
starred reviews from book lists and
library journal and Kirkus Patrick
frickin Rothfuss wrote a blurb for it as
did actually Ford and Katherine Valenti
and several other great writers but I
wanted to sponsor a few wonderful groups
and teams because an absolutely
remarkable thing is such a beautiful
exploration of what humans can
accomplish when we collaborate
effectively I learned of so many
beautiful and worthy projects after I
made that call for sponsorship and I
regret that I had to select so few but
the whole process reminded me that all
the time people are working together to
increase world awesome and decrease
worldsuck from rugby fields to robotics
labs we really can accomplish so much
more together than alone so thank you
for inspiring me an absolutely
remarkable thing comes out in just two
weeks there are links to pre-order in
the doobly-doo below also if you can
come see Hank and me or Hank without me
on the absolutely remarkable thing tour
their shows in Boston and Santa Cruz are
sold out but there's still tickets
elsewhere Hank I hope you liked your
present I will see you on Friday
PS huge thanks to everyone involved in
this project but especially to rosianna
halse rojas who as usual made it all
happen